il ya quarante fois plus de chances
qu'une femme qui a vécu l'exploitation
sexuelle qu'elle décède que la majorité
des femmes du québec
les femmes prostituées sont de grandes
oubliées c'est pour cette raison que
ginette masse et vient au travail tous
les jours elle veut éviter que d'autres
subissent le même sort que marylène
l'évêque assassiné la semaine dernière
mais c'est sûr que l'on était révolté de
voir cette situation là c'est bien
évident que les femmes sur le terrain se
disent mais voyons donc ça n'a aucun
sens on va sacrifier les femmes
prostituées pour réussir à intégrer un
homme dans la société c'est ce qu'on
n'est pas un organisme aide alimentaire
l'eau mais on leur donne un petit coup
de main depuis près de 20 ans la maison
de marques aident les femmes à se sortir
de l'enfer de la prostitution
c'est une douzaine de femmes qui
viennent elle organise des ateliers de
cuisine d'autres activités sociales et
du soutien émotionnel entre autres on
réfléchit aussi est-ce qu'on accueille
les femmes avec leurs enfants dès l'an
prochain
cette maison deviendra le premier centre
d'hébergement au québec pour les femmes
victimes d'exploitation sexuelle
quand on a un besoin que les femmes
entre elles sans rencontre puis qui
parlent de leur propre réalité est
qu'ils puissent se sentent à l'aise d'en
parler donc et c'est pour ça que c'est
important d'avoir de l'hébergement c'est
important aussi pour donner du temps six
mois un an pour que ces femmes se
remettre sur pied
madame ac veut que la maison de marthe
devienne un modèle pour les autres
régions de la province
et on vit des moments historiques
présentement
on est en train d'écrire l'histoire lors
du côté de ressources pour les femmes en
sortie de prostitution c'est pour ces
femmes qu'elle a décidé de prendre la
parole ce soir
il est urgent que des mesures concrètes
soient prises pour stopper les violences
faites aux femmes 14 ans quelles
circonstances et en quelle situation
certaines de ses collègues intervenants
sont venus mener le combat avec elle
dans les autres centres d'hébergement
ils retrouvent parce qu'ils ont besoin
c'est des gros traumatisme et d'agro
sera construction de soi puis y'a rien
y'a rien pour les aider c'est important
d'agir en amont
justement pour contrer cette escalade de
violence le qui fait en sorte cultive
mans ça sera jusqu'au meurtre
la ministre promet des mesures pour
mieux protéger les femmes ces mesures
sont urgentes
c'est comme ça on s'habituait la
population aussi mettez à entendre
parler qu'à eu un drame conjugal à tel
endroit
mais tout se fait à partir d'un même
phénomène il faut surtout pas qu'on sait
bien la maison de marthe dénonce
fortement les violences faites aux
femmes tous ces gens réunis ce soir
espère qu'une telle vigiles ne soit plus
jamais nécessaire qu'il n'y ait plus
d'autres marilyne lévesque
c'est du moins l'ambition de ginette
macé on croit nca c'était meilleur et on
veut que cette société-là 70 ans ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada québec